I know this has been in development for
five or six years
so tell us how it started why you
decided to do this and why you took your
time making this film over that whole
period of time
well I have the privilege to write uh
for actors that I uh uh happen to have a
great communication with and starting
with this gentleman Christian Bale so we
knew we wanted to make something very
ambitious and original something kind of
Epic in its scope that involved themes
of love and friendship who are separated
and reconnected and someone who's really
been through it like all our characters
an underdog and we started discovering
undiscovered history and this informed
the whole picture and we knew we'd have
some characters we would love starting
with Dr Bert Berenson with his back
brace and his one eye and his his
marriage that's a marriage of they won't
love me they won't let me go and uh and
his best friend Harold Woodman and uh
thus began the Journey of this story and
about 14 or 15 drafts of the screenplay
and Margot Robbie became part of the
conversation for about three or four
years of part of that and then there was
De Niro and John David Washington and
the the rest of the cast were actors who
really wanted to come to participate
with us in the movie and so I wrote the
roles for them and uh Christian was
there every step of the way
um and uh it was a great privilege to do
that and he was in the editing room as
well and uh
uh eventually we realized we had a huge
thing that nobody knew in history which
some of my favorite movies have
um they're backing into you have people
you love who are backing into something
that nobody knows the audience doesn't
know it we didn't know it everybody we
talked to didn't know about it
so this is a cool thing for a
Storyteller to have uh as part of the
story for your characters to back into
and for people to go home and talk about
it sure is and it's a movie about so
many things in fact I I told you once
before this is almost like a novel the
way this is written it you know with the
story weaving in and out it's about
people with hope love friendship and as
you just talked about this historical
kind of mix here of real events that I
certainly didn't know about and it's
chilling to watch during that period
what happens but this whole mystery sort
of winds there Christian I gotta ask you
were you told me you were more invested
in this than almost any other movie that
you have made why is that and what's the
kind of Freedom you got in working with
David on creating this character all
along all those years well the
investment comes literally from the
amount of time that David and I spent
and this is the third film that we had
made together and I really appreciate
the the
um uh trust the David showed and invited
me to be involved right from the very
get-go you know before there was any
script whatsoever David had an idea uh
he had some ideas ships and characters
he wanted to describe the character Dr
Burt to me and then have me really think
about that and we did that and we we
really did it with no rush whatsoever I
went and made a couple of films as we
were always meeting in the diners but
then but was always percolating around
him in my brain
and then uh and then yeah throughout the
production as well and then uh David
um is so ridiculously welcoming and
collaborative
um and had me come into the edit room
and I would I would often go like is it
okay and maybe come in today and he was
like dude just anytime you want just
turn up you're welcome all the time and
that was so much fun and a great insight
to me that I've I've never been uh given
permission for uh previously and and
um you know I watched the last 10
minutes of the film and I had a day when
I was just talking with other people
there happened to be parents and we were
talking about
we do watch the news too much and how
much anxiety there seems to be a
particular amount you know nowadays
right now and and and not unfounded uh
reasons for that and then and then I was
playing a game of hide and seek with my
eight-year-old boy right before I left
and that was Lifting me up from the
previous conversation
and uh
thank you mate for bringing me on this
journey because like it it just uh moves
me every time I see it the the even if
it's just the last 10 minutes
I look forward to it I purposely get
here so I can see it because it's a
pick-me-up and it's a real one though
you know it's with absolute grit and
sincerity and these two guys and Valerie
with the two guys you know from working
class backgrounds who did everything
right to pursue the American dream and
then through different prejudices just
get rejected again and to see how they
fight back against what is a seemingly
impossible is ridiculously moving and
uplifting you know and even after making
it you know where you're meant to go
numb to it I'm not numb to this in the
slightest this moves me every single
time to tears and laughter and thank you
mate for for inviting me along in this
year absolutely
and when I say it's hopeful too it shows
it it shows the importance of having
those lone people out there who are
responsible for saving us in many
different facets of history there always
are those people and this movie shows
that as well because it you know it goes
down some scary paths here I have to say
David not only above the line but here
as they say below the line your crafts
all over the map here with a terrific
group of people you've worked with Jay
Cassidy before obviously and I think J.R
you've worked with David on American
Hustle is that right yes I have yeah a
little bit like being in the farm system
my son likes little league so in
baseball so yeah it's it's great to be
on his sets before because I came at it
knowing the full passion and the full
exuberance of his sets and also
um just that ability that like is really
specific to be being on a David set
where he really wants you to emotionally
and passionately be raw and in other
contexts on other sets that feels a
little scary but with David having been
on American Hustle sets and um and I
just knew that that's the safest place
to be is to kind of have all of your
passion in it and he's going to support
you and he's going to want you to do
that so on a hustle it was it was it was
a you know it was like a trial by fire
and I was like oh this is a very
different way to shoot and then when I
could come at it knowing that um on on
this it was incredible it really felt
like like a space where you could let
designs soar from an instinctual place
and he would always support you in that
and to work I have to say Albert
wolski's one of the greats there's no
question I believe he's 91 years old now
he I mean what what Christian you and
Albert did with the 19 131 the storyline
look for for bird is a master class in
in character meets costume design it's a
true master class so with that as the
you know as the inspiration and the
foundation there was nothing else I
could do but bring my a game to
designing the rest of the film
so um it's a it's a big shoes to step
into and I would have I would have died
to have been able to work side by side
with Albert but we couldn't in the
height of omnicron so um I had to bring
it and uh and there is a really you know
I I guess the Young art school girl in
me who got a degree in costume design
and studied the great Albert woolski's
ubra like I mean I'm pinching myself to
be in any orbit of his
um and in a small Love Story Kind of
Love Letter to Albert he designed that
uh black cloak that Valerie wears at the
end he had it totally styled differently
but I called them and told them how
incredible I thought that piece was and
with his Blessing designed the Valerie I
designed the Valerie gown for her
knowing I wanted that piece to land in
the boat scene so even though we
couldn't work side by side together
there's one moment where our both of our
costumes designs will side by side on on
Valerie so
and Jay what is this your fourth or
fifth picture with David
lost count yep
fourth he keeps bringing you back yeah
you know I'm lucky to have Jay back yeah
I mean this is a very passionate editor
well this was you know for me this was
quite
in ways that David hadn't anticipated
um it was a very personal project for me
because my grandfather was in the
American expeditionary Force he ended up
in a hospital
that was uh in
1919 and married the nurse who was the
who was French and uh so and and as well
that place which is still there and it's
now a museum blarencore was was a
creation of Anne Morgan who
brought a sort of well-off well-educated
American women to the devastated region
at the end of the first world war and
that hospital was was she ended up
buying it was an old Chateau and she
ended up buying it and giving it to the
the town of Blair core and so that
little
sort of subplot sort of informed sort of
my feeling about the material
and what were the key challenge for you
this is I think David's kind of first
big Epic movie in terms of spanning
different periods and of course 1918 to
the mid 30s and all of that so what was
a big challenge for you as an editor on
this
it's kind of hard to sort out what was
the challenge the whole thing was the
challenge I think you know and the the
you know you you you know you always
think well I'm older it's going to get
easier and it doesn't you know it's just
you think well I I've learned something
from the other movies no you haven't
learned anything so the
you know I would just sort of say that
there is no one thing that's a challenge
there's just the whole thing's the
challenge but then you have these
incredible occurrences when Daniel
Pemberton fell from the sky and you know
saw the film in London and
um wanted to do the score but wanted to
do it so much he started composing it
before he had the job and he he gave us
the music you know the the the the cues
that you heard basically in a in a kind
of a sketched form he gave us those same
themes he just gave it to us and we
received them and we're like oh my
goodness you know this is landed on this
movie at this moment when it it's just
crying out for this voice
um I gotta thank you all and
congratulate you on Amsterdam it really
is an epic and something that tell
everybody you know it opens on Friday
and congratulations thanks for coming
out tonight thank you Pete thank you
guys thank you guys thank you all for
coming out